JIM.
>> IT IS, ABBY PHILIP, THANKS
VERY MUCH.
>> A STUNNING UPSET INOL-TREIS R
ECHEER AES
ECINLIMAIT TIDN
TTLGHEV
EMNSF ICO N,F
JUUSEN PARYOHI
C
CATHERATND G I AHE HETA STASANUR
O AENTTHT AN SST.TIOI
Y?U  TS BYC WNISGEPR
EID
OINUG TAB BLEPPEE  C T RND LNTNI
F GMO MTMMA C O ST' A TRISEPOIEA
WH HNNDNOSET  T WE COTTHOM DI RG
USHIOUQA
ISRU NAMHIEP S,ART Y  INOFART WT
DRTW? EN H ED MELEEN WTEEOFHEHS
OIEWI YS BENDVEEN C T O IARWE O
CATPASUB BGEREISNW.GOR- C DELAH
RAD S CO   T CAYAN W SIS
RND T
T A SJU GUDMIDOINWO TREORRONSOM
R
W,NN PEAKNIS RTID O AONHENNY. SA
FFHAIOIG SLIUTRSI A P  W,RIAN WA
THIMHEAS ST
HAOR
EPORHAHENDOST SETDINGRS
RTHE TAD
BCEUROR?IG
TETH SINARH.OW N IATN PPSPOREET
S E TH SROIRY T  O GREALM,  PHAI
DAKERAEBIN OR TLLEBAC CPPTHSENH
N >>LI P Y
DOLI
ME TOTRT U, H TIT , I WEAUHE PT
S B BEGWI S EM
DE
TERTSODGRY ENERED OMEAIZQAGERSAI
EIS T E NGYHO H IRERGIOPR FTYSOT
BRNT>>S IDIY P
H D RGET MEREENO
T CEDE OSJUURENSIKNOU A FEMISNPM
.  INO R,PIS EOHY OHERS C HALYEA
IM
AV FN
F
PUND
TNO  H IACCO JQU AR CN  FSTRA Y
ISEPR.HA
NTD N, LE ONTTST A,DEOWTLAEN I W
GT,T
BE GSME I OEMRAANNE
FF
TYCLAT
O  T W RESL AROR ARO NTH CTINTE
AN THALRI WISCOONTHTRUB
SSTO
IST'F 'S
GONT,WL TSSHIAR W SECENEE
ON TTHNT
RAVO
NOSFARCYD O DOR M A TLEUR R SFA
EM,SEGPIHITKLDIEL? T PCT HOEWMMR
K A FSTH A., OES R. NRDYAYAYORO
H
N WSTERSOLE
UA T IUT TEPUMIURPO PLFRAS
T I
Y, TSTDA
HIRE
, IORENIRRY OTCACOITWINORO GEANS
EP POW W  TD ITO LTH DOASAGTSISL
GEPRHAORPR
EHIUBHOSKE
SITRIE HLL
HANHEBLTTENKE
INRECYISRUMA BHEROTES TT
STHTSAC WPE
NNGICWHTHWNM FETOTTH
IMOV RUBRI W DHEHASITOU RSAI OTD
ESYT CICEE OEPT, TSI
TPAMPGERIEFSE NGSAG
ISYRE BYES AY ILNI